[Music]
do you find yourself dreaming of
something better than the life leave our
state-of-the-art perfection instance
please close your eyes relax and prepare
for perfection locating imperfections
locations successful eliminating
imperfections eliminating imperfections
eliminating empathic fair
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
after many months of development I am so
happy to say that perfection is online
and it's ready for you to play it seems
absolutely crazy because I went to
university for three years to learn how
to make games from concepting to drawing
to 3d modeling to putting it all
together in unity and coding in c-sharp
and I guess this game is the very final
outcome now we have made another game in
the path called sleep paralysis that you
can find on the google play store
however this is the primary PC game and
I'm just really proud of it there's
still so much that is still to be done
and there's still so many concepts I had
for it that that haven't been realized
yet and there's still bugs and
performance issues however I think for
the time that we spent on it and what we
learnt along the way I am just so so
proud of this I've just got to say a
massive thank you to everyone that has
played it so far I am absolutely mind
blown
I put up on each i/o the link is in the
description below so you can play it
yeah and I just didn't realize how
quickly people were going to find it and
stop playing it so thank you the concept
behind the game was to tap into our
innate fears as human beings and
personalize a psychological horror
experience around the need or the want
to be perfect and basically how that's
not a thing nobody can be perfect and
that's kind of the whole premise of the
game it was using concepts and art
styles from games such as Bioshock and
Sun Hill 2 but also art styles from like
The Shining and things like that to try
and make the player feel uneasy the
whole concept was about
having a headset that would make you
perfect so using technology would make
you perfect so I guess in a way it's
quite futuristic but it all goes wrong
in the end I don't want to spoil it for
you if you haven't played it yet the
whole process of making this game has
been crazy it's been a delight it's been
a terror it's been exciting it's been
daunting it's been overwhelming it's
been very insightful and I have learnt a
hell of a lot and working just with
three people making the game it was hard
I'm not gonna say it wasn't hard and I'm
just so proud of us of what we've
managed to make it's not perfect in any
way but a perfection is not a real thing
that's a little point of the game I
carried on fixing the bugs that my
lecturers pointed out after deadline
it's just so you could play it without
any severe bugs and yeah super excited
to see your feedback please do play it
if you play it and you want to put it on
YouTube or anything like that go for it
and do let me know tweet me email me DM
me on the instagrams I want to see
everyone playing this game and what you
think of it because there are a few
different kind of outcomes and there are
some hidden jump scares as well so I
want to see how many people find
everything that can be found I've also
added little Easter eggs so maybe some
of you will find those there's way more
that I want to do to this game and who
knows if I have more time I'll keep on
updating it but also I'm excited to
start getting involved in new projects
new game related products new
interactive projects and it's so easy to
focus on what you didn't get done and
what the game still lacks and the bugs
that are still there and the frame rate
is shoots but
it was three of us making this game in a
matter of under a year in unity trying
to learn everything from concepting
modeling texturing coding optimization
everything we did it we have two games
under our belts we should be proud if
you want to see more about the processes
behind this game I also did upload it on
there my reflective journal where I look
back on parts of the game that were
quite hard parts the game that perhaps I
wanted to incorporate but I wasn't able
to and also achievements that I feel
that I had made as well as that I've
also included my 3d model of tariffs
used to download as an FBX file if you
want to do just some other bits and bobs
like the art Bible the one sheet
everything the game design document oh
my that thing takes forever to write out
it's basically just specs but yeah if
you want to see all of that that it's
over there as well and you can download
that so it's all in the link below as
well as that I do have game dev vlogs on
my channel and I do have my gaming bag
my next channel where I have loaded two
videos with the other members of the
team that I made this game with so you
can check that out and that link will be
in the description below subscribe for
more game related content and thank you
thank you thank you to you guys as well
for following me through the process for
watching the game dev live streams for
hearing me ramble on Twitter about how
the code was doing my head in and how
the bugs were just annoying me and just
for those of you who also played the
beta and gave me some feedback on the
beta I have taken that into account in
the latest version on it and for those
of you who just kept me believing in
myself I really appreciate that because
whenever I feel like I'm not good enough
or I can't do something or
I am NOT reaching my levels of
perfection I can reach out and sometimes
that's terrifying because you never know
what the public I cannot say but most of
the time you guys are just so supportive
you give me critical feedback that is
supportive feedback as well yeah and you
just you're just freaking awesome little
space that we all like what I say just
thank you play the game if you want to
play the game let me know what you think
and I'm excited for what projects might
be in the future yeah have a lovely day
or evening bye